[Musique]
pour moi c'était aussi une aide une aide
et une quelque chose que je devais aussi
à mon père je suis libéré quoi comme si
j'étais libéré d'un poids qui me hante
le reste de la semaine
et je me dis que même si notre histoire
est différente bon soit on est un peu
tous dans le même bateau et quand je
réfléchis je reconnais que
l'État français m'a quand même apporté
quand même pas mal
ils n'ont pas le même âge ni la même
histoire et viennent d'horizon
différents mais une chose les relie ils
sont pupilles de la nation
avec ce statut peu connu et unique au
monde réservé aux enfants de victimes de
la guerre ou du terrorisme l'expression
mère patrie prend tout son sens celle
d'une nation qui prend soin de ses
enfants le journal de la défense en a
suivi 5 d'entre eux dans leur
accompagnement par l'onak VG l'Office
national des combattants et des victimes
de guerre
[Musique]
c'est un jour particulier pour Noemie 18
ans et son père reconnu blessé psychique
de guerre après plusieurs opérations
notamment en Nexus et en Afghanistan
ils ont reçu ce matin le courrier tant
attendu du tribunal de grande instance
de Rennes en Ille-et-Vilaine qui
certifie son adoption par la nation
on va regarder ça
du 19 septembre et que le procureur a
donné son avis à commencer à donner son
avis le 29 novembre nous explique
pourquoi je suis devenue plus de la
nation il explique que c'est parce que
lui obéisseur de guerre que tu as eu en
tout le parcours avec la mission en
exubus de la vie en 92 et 95 et puis
l'Afghan en 2009
Gérard avec Anne-sophie
de pupille de la nation parce que mon
père a été déclaré blessé de guerre
c'est une aide et une reconnaissance des
blessés de guerre et des familles de
militaires
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup d'émotions de recevoir ce
courrier puisque pour moi au final après
plus de trois ans de procédure
administratives c'est une vraie
reconnaissance
Noémie donc a pu être adopté puisque
j'ai été reconnu comme ayant été blessés
au combat enfin bien sûr de guerre
psychique me concernant et donc du coup
j'ai appris dans une de mes
hospitalisations que Noémie pouvait
adopter tout au moins vous pouvez faire
un dossier moi j'attends rien de
particulier
de précis c'est juste que Noémie crée
une nouvelle relation tissu une relation
avec quelqu'un d'autre qui n'est pas
dans le domaine familial et qu'elle
puisse se sentir libre d'aborder les
sujets que nous on n'arrivera pas à
aborder avec elle donc notamment sur la
blessure et des choses comme ça donc
c'est de la lettre là pour moi c'était
aussi une aide une aide et une quelque
chose que je devais aussi à mon père
d'être aidé et de pouvoir être suivi
pour aussi avoir une aide et être
compris pour pouvoir me tourner vers
quelqu'un autre que ma famille pour me
confier ou pour parler de la connexion
en 2022 sur près de 1100 pupilles de
moins de 21 ans suivi par le lac BG la
moitié était comme Noémie des enfants de
militaires blessés ou tués en opération
être pupille de la nation c'est d'abord
une reconnaissance de la part de la
nation ça me semble très important on
est bien dans le premier métier la
première mission de l'Office qui est la
reconnaissance et la réparation et c'est
vrai que cela parfois
freine les familles l'adoption par la
nation le mot adoption fait peur alors
il faut rassurer vraiment les familles
qui sont dans cette démarche l'adoption
par la notion est une adoption
symbolique ça ne prive des parents
d'aucun de leurs droits aucun de leurs
droits ça ajoute des droits à l'enfant
mais ça n'en retire pas aux parents
bonjour
[Musique]
bien merci
je vous laisse monsieur jusqu'à mon
bureau
cet assistante de service social à
l'ONUC VG de Rennes accompagné aussi
très autres jeunes dans leur parcours
d'adoption son rôle atténuer le
traumatisme qui a touché leur famille et
les aider à le surmonter voilà s'il y a
des questions le statut pupitre part
d'un événement grave donc forcément ça a
un impact sur l'enfant un impact direct
parce que ça peut être des pupilles
victimes d'attentat direct
ou ça peut avoir un impact à travers
leurs parents
voilà un père qui a un stress
post-traumatique qui s'isole
complètement qui n'arrive plus à aller
au foot avec son fils enfin des choses
comme ça ou même qui arrive plus à
inviter des gens à la maison c'est un
impact et du coup notre rôle c'est
vraiment de les accompagner
essayez de diminuer au maximum cet
impact en passant à travers des aides
pour les psychologues les
psychomotriciens
l'équithérapie essayer d'alléger le
quotidien d'améliorer le quotidien pour
qu'il puisse voilà évoluer plus
normalement possible avec ce statut
suivre et coller le plus possible à tes
besoins c'est pas qu'une institution
froide le Nax c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une maison on peut pas être
insensible en plus à aux situations
qu'on peut rencontrer à travers les
statuts de pupilles donc forcément on
crée quelque chose avec eux complètement
un lien qui se poursuit tout au long de
leur vie ou qu'ils soient les pupilles
pourront toujours compter sur les
services de l'Office mais ce qui a
surtout d'important pour toi c'est que
on est présent dans tous les
départements en France
donc n'importe où tu habitas tu auras
toujours le NAC qui pourra devenir en
aide que ça se fera au niveau
administratif financier enfin voilà on
est là vraiment pour faire un
accompagnement global les pupilles de la
nation sont ressortissants de l'Office
national des combattants et des victimes
de guerre ils sont également
ressortissants d'un mot un peu spécial
que les Français connaissent pas bien
mais nous on l'utilise tout le temps ils
sont ressortissants du code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité des victimes de
guerre donc c'est un statut à vie et en
tant que ressortissant de l'Office ils
ont droit tout au long de leur vie aux
aides de solidarité de l'office
c'est le cas de Sylvain 85 ans son père
est mort en déportation à Auschwitz en
Pologne en septembre 1943
10 ans plus tard le premier février 1952
il est adopté par la nation avec sa sœur
aînée Denise
[Musique]
un acte de décès de mondes mon père avec
la date et il y a marqué la mention mort
pour la France et elle est venue de
guerre elle est passionnés en tant que
dire ma mère m'a dit tu vas vite voir le
directeur parce que tu as droit une
bourse donc j'arrive c'est le directeur
je me rappelle très bien au collège
Chaponnay à Lyon ou tout de suite j'ai
eu une bourse pendant quatre ans donc
sixième cinquième quatrième troisième
donc c'est plus puissant à ce moment-là
j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu un changement
d'attitude uniquement des professeurs
mais comme indical si on vous taire
royalement
ça allait déranger pas que je change
juif pas juif bon si pas possible mais
les le prof tous les profs me
considérait davantage j'avais
l'impression d'exister
les années ont passé le NAC VG a
toujours veillé sur Sylvain
des aides ponctuelles ont amélioré son
quotidien et compenser une petite
retraite
comme une cure pour se remettre de la
covid-19 ou le remplacement d'un
appareil en panne
est vrai que depuis quelques années où
on a un frigo un petit peu un problème
le lac budgétiseur une partie voire la
totalité mais bon mais c'est vrai que
deux fois par an
leak
financière
on a toujours un geste vous voyez le
fait de d'avoir cette interview et de de
remettre à flot toute cette histoire
fait que ça ressort mais quand je
réfléchis je reconnais que
l'État français m'a quand même apporté
quand même pas mal
le statut de pupille de la Nation est
une particularité française sans
équivalent ailleurs
c'est un héritage de la Grande Guerre un
conflit qui laisse derrière lui près
d'un virgule 4 millions de morts ou
disparus mais aussi près de 4 millions
de blessés 600.000 veuves et près d'un
million d'orphelins
la question de leur prise en charge se
pose
[Musique]
ils étaient plein et il fallait s'en
occuper ne pas s'en occuper c'était
scandaleux ben non là il y avait un
consensus il y avait une union sacrée je
sais aussi une époque où on commence à
spécialiser la justice pour enfants où
vous avez un service social de l'enfance
qui se constitue et puis vous avez un
mouvement alors un phénomène qui va
jouer un peu pour l'adoption législative
c'est la laïcité parce que la guerre a
suscité un raz-de-marée philanthropique
vous n'avez pas idée du nombre de de
centre de rééducation de de foyer de
maisons du soldat qui ont été créés par
des gens riches il y avait une maison
importante et qui est donc consacrée à
ça notamment les œuvres catholiques et
donc vous avez eu des orphelines à
catholiques qui se sont
que c'est de prendre en charge les
orphelins et pour la République laïque
c'était un peu un défi donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont créés l'Office
sous la coupe sous la tutelle du
ministère de à l'époque on dit de
l'instruction publique c'est office des
pupilles est instauré par l'État en 1917
officiellement il est rattaché à une
institution profondément laïque et déjà
d'ailleurs interpréter cette haïtité de
façon très très souple car
laïcité ne veut pas dire sectarisme et
donc le dogme que auquel tiennent les
anciens combattants c'est que les
enfants doivent recevoir l'éducation que
leur père aurait voulu il faut respecter
le droit du père la volonté du Père ça
c'est le principe fondamental à partir
de 1935 l'Office des pupilles fusionne
avec plusieurs organismes pour devenir
l'Office national des combattants et des
victimes de guerre que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui et désormais rattaché au
ministère des armées depuis le statut a
été étendu à d'autres catégories de
victimes
aujourd'hui pour devenir pupille de la
nation l'enfant doit être âgé de moins
de 21 ans révolu
un de ses parents ou tuteurs légaux doit
avoir été blessé ou tuer lors d'une
guerre d'un acte de terrorisme ou lors
d'une agression dans le cadre d'une
mission de service public
ou être lui-même victime de la guerre ou
du terrorisme
une fois adoptée l'enfant devient
ressortissant de l'Office national des
combattants et des victimes de guerre
il bénéficie à ce titre d'une aide
morale et d'un soutien financier
en 2022 126 pupilles ont été adoptés par
la nation dont 78 enfants de militaires
tués ou blessés en opération
46 au titre du terrorisme et deux pour
des actes d'agression
[Musique]
près de 5 millions d'euros ont été
consacrés pour l'ensemble des pupilles
soit près de 20% du budget total de
l'action sociale de l'ONUC VG pour
accompagner les pupilles l'Office
dispose de 104 services de proximité un
dans chaque département en France
métropolitaine et en outre-mer ainsi
qu'en Algérie et au Maroc
[Musique]
Havane nous retrouvons Anne Gélin
directrice départementale de Launac VG
du Morbihan elle accompagne une
quarantaine de pupilles de la nation de
moins de 21 ans
comment allez-vous ce jour-là Anne Gélin
reçoit Solène veuve de guerre et maman
de deux enfants
alia 15 ans et Ethan 13 ans
leur père militaire est décédé des
suites de ses blessures en Afghanistan
en 2009
en préfecture et là aussi on a le projet
au 11 novembre et bien de réitérer avant
la cérémonie à Vannes bien sûr la
préfecture du Morbihan comme c'est la
maison de l'État et bien de recevoir
aussi les familles et les enfants donc
là c'est un projet donc je reviendrai
vers vous mais là on a un petit peu plus
de temps ça sert à la fin d'année je me
suis rendu compte que voilà l'aspect
social était primordiale et c'était et
c'était justement ce qui me plaît
beaucoup dans notre métier qui est
vraiment de terrain n'oublions pas qu'on
a un service de proximité donc c'est
vraiment
l'accueil l'accueil toujours dans la
bienveillance et puis beaucoup d'écoute
j'ai la possibilité d'avoir un local
comme je vous avais dit d'accord donc ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle je croise les
doigts pour que ça se fasse alors il y a
les aides mais il y a la partie qui est
très importante c'est l'écoute c'est la
disponibilité on se sent ici enfin moi
personnellement c'est mon point de vue
je j'ai toujours plaisir à venir voir
les personnes qui travaillent à le NAC
on se connaît depuis des années c'est
aussi une fierté et puis c'est une
c'est une confiance aussi parce que si
demain moi il m'arrive quelque chose il
y a ça aussi il y a le poids de le poids
de la responsabilité qui est là aussi
jusqu'au 18 ans c'est le soulagement on
va dire au 18 ans même si on sait
qu'après ça continue derrière c'est de
se dire que ben ils seront quand même
jamais réellement seul en fait il y a
c'est comme une famille en fait ça
s'arrête pas effectivement à 18 ou à 21
ans par exemple c'est tout au long de la
vie ponctuellement ils savent qu'ils
peuvent se tourner vers leur service
vers le service départemental où il
réside bien sûr de l'Office donc ça peut
être des aides financières ponctuelles
ça peut être
une reconversion professionnelle par
exemple mais aussi les endroits réservés
et puis les aides financières
certainement pas alia Ethan les enfants
de Solène ont grandi sans leur père mais
ils sont accompagnés depuis leur
naissance par l'Office
ce statut pour moyen important
parce que on a comme besoin de certaines
aides par exemple moi je vois une
éducatrice c'est un apport que qui me
fait du bien en fait de temps en temps
voilà ça me fait une sortie je peux me
confier à une personne en qui j'ai
confiance et puis voilà donc c'est lonac
qui aide pour ça
pareil donc pour le sport voilà donc mon
activité personnelle c'est du volley
mais il faut savoir que c'est ma
première année avant j'ai fait
d'équitation c'est comme un sport qui
coûte assez cher et je pense que
réellement sansonna que j'aurais jamais
pu faire ce sport au-delà des aides les
adolescents participent souvent aux
événements organisés par l'Office 2017
je crois on a été invité pour la
cérémonie du 11 novembre
à Paris avec la cérémonie à l'Arc de
Triomphe donc j'ai pu rencontrer le
président de la République
et on a été ensuite invité à l'Elysée
pour un discours du président et on a pu
rencontrer plein d'autres pupilles du
coup je me rends compte que chaque
histoire n'est pas la même en fait il y
a vraiment beaucoup d'histoires
différentes qui peuvent être touchantes
etc enfin c'est vraiment spécial et je
me dis que même si notre histoire est
différente dans son on est un peu tous
dans le même bateau donc c'est vrai que
ça fait plaisir de rencontrer des gens
qui qui peuvent nous comprendre
très habitué à ce genre dans les années
1980 la France subit une vague
d'attentat le statue de pupille de la
nation est alors étendu aux enfants
victimes du terrorisme
une extension qui a pris tout son sens
récemment plus de 130 pupilles ont été
adoptées par la nation au titre des
attentats de 2015 à Paris et de 2016 à
Nice à partir de 1986
il y a la reconnaissance des victimes
d'acte du terrorisme notamment sous
l'impulsion de de
de personnalité j'ai une petite pensée
pour Madame Françoise rudetzky qui est
décédé en 2022 et qui a été l'une des
personnalités qui s'est battue pour que
les victimes d'acte du terrorisme
bénéficient d'un statut et c'est la loi
du 23 février
1990 qui ouvre aux victimes d'attentats
les dispositions le bénéfice des
dispositions du code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité et des victimes
de guerre et parmi ces dispositions il y
a le statut de pupille de la nation donc
à partir de 1990 les victimes dagues du
terrorisme peuvent se voir reconnaître
le statut de pupille de la nation
en 2020 Noam disant et Marius 7 ans sont
adoptés pour ce motif
les deux frères étaient présents avec
leurs parents à l'attentat de Barcelone
en 2017
ce jour-là sur la Rambla une camionnette
fonce sur la foule dans la famille
personne n'est blessée mais le
traumatisme vécu est réel de retour chez
eux à Rennes en Bretagne le père Étienne
est reconnu victime d'actes de
terrorisme
il découvre en parallèle le statut de
pupille de la nation et seront à l'onak
VG pour se renseigner au début j'étais
un petit peu réticent comme beaucoup de
parents et en fait ils ont été très très
pédagogues et ils m'ont vraiment
expliqué
pourquoi il était important que les
enfants soient plus petits
on se rend pas compte mais on a vécu
quelque chose de fort quelque chose qui
reste dans la tête et même si on se dit
il y aura pas besoin nos enfants n'ont
pas besoin faut savoir que que les
enfants c'est des éponges et ils ont
vraiment vraiment
besoin d'aide que ce soit de suite ou
par la suite on peut se retrouver du
jour au lendemain sans travail parce que
on se sent plus capable de travailler
d'exercer ce qu'on fait et là vraiment
c'est c'est très important d'avoir en
fait ce soutien aussi financier que
moral à notre conseillère
c'est un an j'allais là pour nous on se
sent bien en fait si vous voulez on se
sent accompagné et c'est vrai que ça
c'est très très important lorsqu'on a
lorsqu'on a vécu quelque chose de fort
on se sent accompagné ils sont là et on
sait que ils seront là tout le temps
pour nos enfants
pour Etienne c'était aussi le moyen de
faire reconnaître le traumatisme
familial j'étais reconnu victime
d'attentat et ma femme et mes enfants
étaient à 3 mètres de moi mais à
l'intérieur d'un monument donc eux n'ont
pas été reconnus en fait victime
d'attentat donc je me sentais tout seul
alors qu'on était tous en famille et le
fait que mes enfants soient aujourd'hui
pupilles de la nation
c'est quelque chose aussi c'est une
reconnaissance pour moi et pour eux
regarde c'est sympa oh regarde ça
bonjour le plus petit Marius voit une
psychomotricienne pour l'aider à
canaliser son énergie
depuis quelques mois son grand frère
Noam apprend à gérer ses émotions avec
de l'équithérapie une suggestion de
l'onak VG
au début on était allé voir en fait une
psychologue pour mon fils ça n'avait pas
Mathieu ça n'avait pas marché et l'ONAC
veget nous a conseillé de faire de
l'équithérapie et c'est vrai que les
guitares aujourd'hui c'est un certain
budget tout le monde ne peut pas en
faire et grâce à l'ONAC grâce au
subventions c'est une aide aussi
psychologique qui permet en fait à Noam
de pouvoir avancer et de se sentir bien
puisque c'est quelque chose qu'il
apprécie il aime le contact avec
l'animal avec le cheval c'est vraiment
quelque chose bah qui le fait se sentir
mieux et il peut extérioriser et il peut
parler des choses qui peut pas forcément
parler avec nous ou avec d'autres
personnes en fait quand je suis thérapie
je suis en contact avec le cheval c'est
mais en fait c'est
je suis libéré quoi comme si j'étais
libéré d'un poids qui me hanter le reste
de la semaine c'est en fait quand je
suis à côté de lui je sens qu'il est
thérapeutique quoi je suis vraiment
voilà il m'apaise
elle va peut-être être intriguée par
là-bas donc reste bien concentré avec
elle soit sûre de où tu vas pendant les
séances Noam est accompagné par une
équipe sienne dont le métier consiste à
mettre en relation les chevaux avec des
personnes en situation de handicap de
fragilité ou de souffrance
elle s'appelle Amy et je pense bah du
bien Dell je trouve que c'est pas comme
une psy mais c'est une personne qui
m'aide beaucoup
en psychologie tu te sens un peu mis à
la pression quand ils sont dans une scie
alors que là-bas tu sais très bien que à
notre dans sa tête mais elle garde sa
pour elle
c'est complémentaire en fait ça offre
juste une autre un autre cadre un autre
lieu pour discuter et après Noam ça va
être aussi toute cette notion de plaisir
là de aussi on travaille un petit peu
sur l'affirmation de soi ce qui est
beaucoup mieux aussi avec Noam on va
beaucoup discuter en fait on a des temps
voilà en début de séance on va parler de
lui sa semaine ou revenir justement sur
ces passer là aussi
ça fait quelque chose que je le vois
bien je le vois souriant et c'est
agréable et limite c'est envie de
pleurer dire que ton fond il se sent
bien il est bien et voilà c'est trop et
elle fait un travail incroyable et on la
remercie mes mains sur ta main avec ce
statut de pupille la nation assure son
devoir de mémoire et de reconnaissance
envers ses enfants et leur famille
un statut qui depuis plus d'un siècle a
su évoluer au regard de l'histoire avec
comme première mission toujours la
réparation
[Musique]